19 août 1944 paris se soulève contre
l'occupant allemand
mais l'insurrection est en difficulté
le 25 août à 13h hitler apprend que les
forces alliées ont atteint le centre de
la capitale française
secoué par un accès de rage
hitler creek il a donné des ordres
nécessaires pour que la vie soit
anéantie il interroge yodleurs frappant
du poing sur la table
je veux savoir paris brûle-t-il paris
est il oui ou non en train de brûler
paris brûle-t-il
c'est l'histoire de la libération de
paris c'est aussi le livre de dominique
lapierre et larry collins
c'est enfin un film que vient de
commencer 21 ans après le réalisateur
rené clément
et depuis quelques jours de 5h à 7h du
matin les rues les avenues de paris sont
déserts la libération de paris re
commence au milieu
d'énormes difficultés nous avons demandé
à rené clément comment il avait accepté
de faire revivre cette épopée
cette fresque inoubliable que fut la
libération de paris
lui qui avait commencé pour son premier
long métrage par un film sur la
résistance
la bataille du rail
quand on m'a proposé de conte et paris
brûle-t-il la production de monsieur
paul grèce mais quand même très tentée
en me donnant si je puis dire quelque
chose que tout le monde voulait
attribuer enfin exemple quand vous
additionnez votre à ses soucis j'ai fini
par accepter malgré l'énormité du
travail que cela représente
les difficultés l'impossibilité parce
que total de faire ce film je vous dis
tu as possibilités presque totale et
pourtant vous faites ce film en ce
moment alors oui on tombe quand même
alors c'est là où j'ai une équipe
extraordinaire qui a accepté le défi
aussi nous sommes deux équipes
j'ai enlevé ce mac vous travaillez avec
moi il est un spécialiste
c'est extraordinaire mais qui comprend
exactement mon père est comme ces dix
mois qu'il faisait qui lui de son côté
va participer par par une sorte de conte
défait de contrechamp menace pas pour
comment dirais-je nous allons créer
je vais créer une réalité et les caméras
vont se jeter dessus c'est grâce aussi
au ministère qui ont voulu nous
comprendre qu'ils ont très bien compris
la chose à la préfecture de police qui
nous est d'une façon extraordinaire
maintenant je peux le voir constater
puisque ça fait déjà le troisième jour
de tournage et grâce aussi aux parisiens
qui sont devenus des excellents de bonne
volonté
quel effet cela vous prenez de revoir
tout rencarde rappelle des mauvais
souvenirs
le tout avec ces faits mais c'est faire
de
de faire un film justement sur cette
libération de paris
pourquoi donc
aux jambes
c'est pas pour nous et 300 pour ces
faits
m
j'avais
les jeunes vers les 16 17 18 ans pendant
les quatre ans de guerre
ça fait drôle là les taxis tous années
de petit vélo là aussi vous avez tous
venus pour vous c'était extraordinaire
de libération de paris c'était une
grande joie
sortie et de revoir ces gens habillés
comme ça vous avez début mai
justement ces situations là aussi
et les chaussures par les chaussons
arrêter lange en effet mme albert
allez fabriquer pour adapter un ouvrage
aussi important une histoire aussi grand
là aussi il a fallu combien il avait
plusieurs il y avait plusieurs scénarios
de fait il y à une tentative justement
où la multiplicité avaient été
respectées comme dans le livre enfin
respecter pour une part parce que s'il
fallait faire le livre sera un film qui
durera une semaine
ça a duré presque autant que la
libération de paris et cela n'aurait pas
été possible sera coûté un prix
épouvantable donc la production ne s'est
pas arrêté à ce scénario là il y en
avait un autre qui a été écrit par gore
vidal et qui lui assure davantage cette
idée de continuité dans dans les faits
on fait un film historique vous basez
donc son effet maintenant il ne verra de
certaines choses à réinventer agresseurs
et puis les vous dites historiques
c'est un an que nous n'aimons pas
beaucoup les scénaristes et moi dans
cette affaire à faire un film historique
pour moi c'est sûrement en faire un film
ennuyeux
puis qu'est ce que voulait faire un film
historique au fond on peut peut-être que
dire pour lui période très éloigné de
nous ou fond le vrai film historique
alors ce voile est un film de faire
machine c'est vrai ça maintenant vous
disiez très justement tout à l'heure
fresque au même titre que la bataille du
rail en effet une fresque
oui c'est intéressant parce que voyez
vous qu'est ce qui est caractéristique
dans la fresque
c'est que à un moment donné d'une façon
vraiment c'est là une passionnante
vous voyez une action se transformer et
devenir autre sans aucun rapport avec
une réalité comme on prétend dire
naturaliste et détestable mais se
transformer et prendre notre corps par
des voies plus nobles puissant les oies
dollar et ça c'est intéressant et c'est
plus passionnant est beaucoup plus
dramatique
malgré tout bien reconnaître que
les les histoires les récits de guerre
ont un pouvoir dynamique révéler c'est
un révélateur c'est un bain révélateur
pour voir s'il est des caractères pour
voir se créer des hommes où se détruire
d'autres hommes c'est peut-être aussi
une côté psychologique de ces différents
personnages soient intéressés eh bien
oui dans la mesure où ces périodes là
sont particulièrement révélatrice en
caractères en sommes
vous voyez des ses classiques c'est bien
connu on voit apparaître des caractères
des visages et des tempéraments des
beautés de conscience qu'on ne soupçonne
et quelquefois pas exactement l'inversé
si les noms ont tourné quelques fois
horrifiés de l'ain certaines choses
selon le capitaine serge le capitaine
serge est un fou a fait fi qui en
réalité est à la solde de la gestapo et
qui a vendu les 35 jeunes gens qui ont
été fusillés à cascades de bonal
s'aligne aux personnages
ce n'est pas difficile justement de
camper un personnage aussi le fait qu'on
presse
c'est difficile parce que humainement
c'est un personnage mais enfin d'un
point de vue et acteur matam est
intéressante parce que j'ai pas
tellement une tête de [ __ ] alors je
suis plus libre de jouer à halo ça
m'intéresse de jouer des personnages en
pâte qui ne ressemble pas parfait
cigarette merci
jacques bigot le web ça commence bien
les mollahs sont tous des copains on est
du même rooney quelle est votre attitude
à face la nouveau signe en général
d'être le premier c'est le premier c'est
toujours le premier c'est terrifiant
c'est terrifiant
on a l'impression qu'on ne sait plus
rien que tout à refaire tout à
réapprendre toutes les difficultés sont
nouvelles
quand vous avez fini un film et quand
c'est le énième vous dise
bon maintenant quand même le sujet je
suis pareil pour beaucoup de choses et
puis finalement vous apercevez que le
nouveau importe du problème complètement
différent des difficultés auxquelles
nous attendait pas et qui de nouveau
vous demande d'autres expériences dans
ses expériences une fois acquises vont
vous servir pour le prochain qui vous
demandera d'autres encore c'est une
énorme encyclopédie
le fait nouveau qui est la preuve
j'imagine
il balance ses agissements mais là
dessus bon alors je ne sont pas inquiet
vote et il marque bak disent pas tous
deux allés ramasser une de ses affiches
par terre la méningite en poche
et voilà à peu près les mêmes enquêtes à
faire donc que vous êtes ici vous
constatez donc qui se passe quelque
chose maintenant contre on sait que les
excuses de tracts sur les murs il se
passe quelque chose longtemps qu'est-ce
que ça peut bien être parmi les très
nombreux acteurs de paris brûle-t-il
vous avez pu reconnaître que jean louis
trintignant jean paul belmondo incarne
yvon morandat qui le 21 août son parasol
de l'hôtel matignon avec sa secrétaire
claire dans le film marie virginie
ce sont là trois personnages parmi ceux
qui prendront encore tout au long de ce
tournage de paris brûle-t-il qui feront
revivre les moments les plus
fantastiques de la libération de paris
vous